この動画では研究へのインパクトと不正、グレー事案ということについてお話しさせていただければというふうに思います。
研究へのインパクトというところで、もちろん加速させている部分はあると思います。
探索や視察調べが楽になった、ようやく作文が楽になった、行動、過剰検証が早くなった、一方で人が握っているべき場所もあるわけですね。
取り立てる、検証する、責任を負うなどの部分でございます。
これら、いろいろと変わっていますが、AIについてよく使われているようなところの領域ではですね、
例えばですけど、英文構成とかコード整形にAIを使うのは全然深刻なのもいらないよと。
手法の一部としてAIを使うならそれは明記していないと。
ただ、そこで精査した主張であったりとか、出てきた結果だったりを鵜呑みにして、
無検証で出すのは厳禁だし、出てきた引用自体をですね、そのままペタッとあって載せるというのも厳禁だということを言っているようなケースもあったりします。
どこに線引きがあるかって結構変わってきている状態なんですね。
実際リスクが結構増えていると思うんですよ。ハルシネーションを最もらしい誤りの混入というのがあります。
それがですね、巧妙に最もらしいと人間に気づくのが大変でですね、自分で生成している分には、あまりそういうことって起こり得ない間違いなのかもしれないですけど、
AIの出力に対する間違い探しをずっとする羽目になるということがあるわけですね。
それから速さに検証コストが追いつかないというのは、
まあ、砂糖とかも間に合わなかったりするし、
結果がボンボンボンボン出てくるんですけど、
それをですね、人間が見ていくというのがめちゃくちゃ大変になってしまっているということです。
学術と信頼性の問題があったりとか、そもそも人間が本質に考えるといけない点があるのかみたいなことがあるわけですね。
なので、AIをどう考えるかというのは、分野差があるということを一つ前の動画でもご説明したかと思います。
AIの功績というのは、実は語彙に出るということを言われていまして、
このデルブという単語がですね、むちゃくちゃ生成AIが出てから増えたとかですね、
クルーシャルという語彙も増えたみたいなことがあります。
これ実はパンデミックとかエボラみたいなですね、
そういう単語が増えたときと実は結構似ているようなんですけども、
1500万件のですね、パウメイドという公開データになっている論文集みたいなのがあるんですけど、
そのアブストラフトをですね、分析した結果、
チャートGPT始まってからいきなり増えた声があるようなんですね。
2020年のアブストラフトのスラフトの13.5%はLNM処理なんじゃないかと、
分野によっては最大40%ぐらいになるんじゃないかということが言われていますと。
影響の大きさというのはですね、このパンデミックは0.04ですから、
それに比べるとですね、遥かにボコンって上がっているように見えるということなんですね。
なので、影では結構使われているんじゃないかということも言われたりするわけです。
なので、そうしたようなですね、
みんな使っているから赤信号が当たればいいですよねというふうにはなかなかならないという現状で、
今一度ですね、この最初出しましたけど、サイエンスの線引きみたいな、
ご自身の分野での線引きは確認する必要があるかなと思います。
例えばですけど、絶対に負荷だよと言ってもサイエンスあるわけですよ。
頭脳生成とかですね、作読関係とかね。
もちろん、捏造はFFPでダメですし、著者化というのもダメですよね。
それから、いよいよ開示で可能というのはあるんですけど、
研究の実施にかかる部分なので、
これは逆に言えば、
データを作っていく段階からですね、
十分AIを使ったということを変えていかないとダメだということですね。
問題が小さい部分というのは、文献の下調べとかですね、
言語構成とか大丈夫だよということで可能だと言われているんですけど、
こういうふうなですね、
この2つ、特に要開示でかというのは何なのかとか、
これすらアウトだというのを理解する必要があるのかなというふうに思います。
グレーをどう見分けるかということですね、
これ前の動画でも言ったのと結構被ってきているんですが、
迷ったらこの4つということでですね、
僕が考えているのは、
例えば開示前に、開示を前提にすると、
つまりそれを書くことができるかどうか、
記録をとっておく、
ここを使ったよというのは後から出せるかどうか、
ルールと合っているか検証をする、
投稿先、協調者のルールを確認する、
それから責任の所在を考えるということですね、
それってあなたが本当に責任を取って、
全部倒しようと言えるかどうかということですね、
あるいは出てきたことの内容を、
あなたが評価できないといけないですよね、
一つでもいい絵があればですね、
その使い方では結構まずいんじゃないのということでございます。
なので、禁止というよりはですね、
研究設計とか、そういう問題が大きいんですね。
なので、しっかりとですね、
この4つのルールを見た上でですね、
安全な活用をしていただければというふうに思います。
ということで、今回の動画はここまででございました。
とりあえずこの4つ、皆さんぜひ日頃から考えてみてください。
あ、そうだ、一応言っておきましょう。
修論とかもですね、
同じように、
こういうふうにあろうとなっている場合ありますからね。
例えば、
なんか引用文献全然ないんだけど、
みたいなことで、
白紙論文が撤回になったとか、
いろいろあると思います。
十分に気をつけるようにお願いいたします。